[Applause]
[Music]
this week you can fight shoot dig and
drive your way through new releases
there's something for everybody unless
you're really into ponies I don't have
any of those for you this week but hey
if you hit that subscribe button you
just might see some of those majestic
animals in a future episode for now
let's talk about some of the biggest
games launching this week in case you're
wondering why it's not called Marvel vs.
Capcom for infinite is all about the
Infinity stones Marvel's Ultron teams up
with megaman x's sigma to merge the
universes and conquer everything but
you'll have a big roster of fighters
ready to stop them including newcomers
like Black Panther Captain Marvel and
Jetta beyond the hefty story mode there
are plenty of fights to be had and
ranked and casual matches online the
Infinity stones themselves have a place
in combat to the mine stone for example
performs a full stun command grab you
can throw down on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Tuesday September 19th what's next from
the team behind grow home and grow up a
game about growing while shooting of
course but at Omega isn't just about
taking down your opponents you can also
collect mass to grow and change your
shape the bigger you get the more
powerful you are but you become a much
easier target between the 8 different
forms you can take and ten power-ups it
sounds like a fun time up to eight
players can compete on PC on the 19th
fingers cross for a Stay Puft DLC skin
for the bigger characters
if you'd rather explore then shoot a
bunch of people why not check out
steamworld dig too just like the first
game this sequel is all about mining
that means making your way through the
earth and collecting or and other
resources plus a bit of battling
underground enemies and a dash of
Metroidvania style platforming
steamworld dig to comes to Nintendo
switch on Thursday the 21st then to PC
on the 22nd with ps4 and Vita releases
the following week
alright let's stick with the switch but
go back to beating people up if you
missed your chance to play pokken
tournament on Wii U then DX is the way
to go
it has everything from the original plus
new pokemon from the arcade release not
to mention the debut of Sun and moons
tessa dua
new modes like team battle are also
included and you won't have to grind a
way to unlock all the contenders every
pokemon is available from the start you
can choose from over 20 to duke it out
on the 22nd and now let's take a final
lap with Project cars 2 with almost 200
cars and dozens of tracks to race you
have plenty of options for cruising
around
not to mention online races and
championships if you want to test your
mettle the sequel also adds a VR option
but if you're all about the prettiest
experience without a headset you'll be
happy to know that it supports up to 12
K resolution across three monitors you
can get as hardcore with your racing as
you want when project cars 2 comes to
ps4 Xbox one and PC on the 22nd and
those are some of the hottest games
we'll be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys and I'll
be back with another batch of new
releases next week